Hi, welcome back.
In the last session we talked about how
equity research analysts, sell-side
analysts, spend significant amounts of
their time trying to forecast what the a
company's earnings will be in the next
quarterly release.
In this session I want to focus more
specifically on that day when earnings
are released and how the market reacts
to earnings reports. After all, this is
the most common way in which companies
reveal information to public investors
is reports. Four times a year in the US
and much of the and increasingly in much
of the world.
So let's talk about those
announcements and why it is so difficult
to gauge whether it's good news or bad
news.
As I as I mentioned earlier, this is
your primary device as a company to let
the world know what your operations are
doing, how much your revenues are, what
your margins look like, what your
earnings are. And that information tells
you not just what the business is doing,
what the company's business is doing,
but it does give you information about
the sector, sometimes about the
competition.
Not surprisingly, when earnings report
comes out there's a price effect.
Now at first sight you're saying at at
first your first reaction would be
that's obvious. If earnings go up the
stock price should go up, if the
earnings go down stock price should go
down. Not necessarily and here's why.
When an earnings report come out comes
out, markets don't react to the report
per se, but what the report contains is
news relative to what they expected to
say.
Put simply,
a high growth company that reports a 30%
growth in earnings might have a negative
surprise because people are expecting a
40% growth. A declining company that
reports a 5% drop in earnings might see
its stock prices go up because people
are expecting a 10% drop.
This is an expectations game and actual
numbers are compared to expectations.
We'll talk about what goes in those
expectations. Sell-side analysts used to
be the drivers of those expectations,
but increasingly the market seems to
have a created a mind of its own.
So, you got the earnings report day, and
you look at actual numbers come out to
compare it to expectations.
Now, when you look at the earnings
reports themselves, usually companies
report earnings on pretty much the same
day every year. So, if your first
quarter earnings come out in April 16th,
you should expect to see the earnings
report next year. We'll talk about what
happens when companies delay reports
relative to expected date.
They reveal information to their about
their current and future product, and
increasingly, as we will see, they
supplement that information about what
happened in the last quarter
with guidance about what they see coming
up in the future. And as I mentioned, in
an efficient market, there should be an
instantaneous reaction to the earnings
report. If it contains better than
expected news, your price should pop up.
Worse than expected news should drop
down, but roughly the amount it should,
and then you should see no drift
afterwards.
So, we know what we should expect to
see. Let's see what the actual earnings
report reactions look like in the
market.
In this graph,
you know, what what the researchers did
is they broke down earnings reports
based on the surprise, where actual
earnings were compared to expected
earnings from most positive to most
negative. So, the blue are the the
companies that report the most positive
earnings surprises, earnings being
greater than expected. The red at the
bottom is the most negative.
And this
in this study, they looked at what the
stock prices were in the days around the
earnings announcement, starting third,
you know,
60 days before, going 60 days after.
Now, first thing you will notice is day
zero is the earnings report. You see
that prices tend to start drifting in
the days before.
And they drift in the right direction.
The most positive reports you start to
see stock prices increase fairly
substantially
in the 6, 7, 8 days before the report.
Now, you could you could be one of those
great market efficiency believers who
says show this shows you how markets can
forecast what's coming. Or you could be
a cynic and say this suggests there's
some leakage of information. Which is a
nice way of saying somebody's trading on
this public information before it goes
public. We'll hold our noses and hold on
because clearly there is a drift up or
down depending on what's included in the
report.
The earnings report comes out. There is
an additional effect which is
consistent. So we have a very positive
earnings report. In addition to the
drift up in the days before, on the day
or the moment of the announcement you
see the stock price go up.
But then if you track it in the days
after, it continues to drift upwards.
And that's interesting because that is
not consistent with an efficient market.
The most negative reports, there's a
drift down before the report, there's a
drop on the day of the report, and then
there's a drift down in the days after.
In fact, if you focus just on that
post-announcement drift, first thing to
recognize, we're not talking about 100%
or 80%. It's a fairly modest drift, but
it is a drift.
In the in the 60 days after the most
positive reports,
the stock price goes up about 5% more
than expected.
After the most negative reports, it goes
down about 2%
more than expected. So -2%.
So there's a post-announcement drift.
And that is something we're going to
talk about as investors is there a way
to take advantage of it.
So earnings reports affect stock prices
consistently. Good news in the form of
positive surprises.
Now, the question is how are
expectations formed? The way in which
these studies were constructed is they
use analyst expectations as the base,
they compare the actual number.
And until about 10, maybe even 20 years
ago, that used to be legitimate. Analyst
expectations became the expected number.
But one of the things that started
happening is companies started gaming
the system and beating analyst
expectations more frequently than they
should. Because remember, if these
expectations are unbiased, half the time
you should beat expectations, half the
time you should not. There's some
sectors like technology where companies
were beating expectations 80% of the
time. The market learns. In what way? If
you consistently beat expectations by
5%, you know what the market's going to
do, right? If your earnings come in 3%
higher than expected, that's going to be
viewed as a negative surprise. Something
to think about as you look at these
studies is how that expectations game
has changed.
Earlier I talked about how earnings
reports tend to come out on a particular
day every year.
This There's one study that looked at
what happens to earnings reports that
come out earlier than expected, which
are relatively few,
and later than expected, which happens
fairly frequently. So, company's
earnings date is April 17th, April 17th
comes and goes, and there is no earnings
report. April 18th comes and goes, no
earnings report. It's delayed by a day,
delayed by 2 days. Now, stop and think
about it. As investors, when you see an
earnings report delayed,
what's your first reaction?
There must be some bad news, right?
Nobody with good news is going to delay
the report. And you can see already how
markets have to behave accordingly. And
the longer you delay a report,
the more your price drifts down because
people are building in the expectation,
that probably rightly, that you're more
likely to be conveying bad news.
And finally, if you focus on the day of
the announcement itself, and this is a
study that looked at how quickly prices
adjust, and looked at the immediate
impact, and then tracked the stock one
month one hour after, two hours after,
three hours after. This is across all
stocks.
Across all stocks, about 91%
of the price reaction has happened
within three hours of the report. What
does that mean? If you're going to be
trading on earnings reports, you better
be trading in time because you wait
three hours after the report, much of it
is faded.
And if you look at the most liquid
stocks, this adjustment is even faster.
It's in
In fact, one of the interesting things
again that has happened in markets is
because these reports often come out
after close of trading.
And there is, you know, you can actually
see the pre-market price of the company.
The adjustment actually happens in the
pre-market. And by the time the stock
opens the next day, almost all of the
adjustment has happened in the most
liquid stocks.
So, when you look at these earnings
reports and how they affect prices,
there are some things that seem to come
out. First is the quality of earnings
seems to matter.
Company comes out and says, you know,
its earnings were 10% higher than
expected. That's good news, right?
But it also has to reveal its entire
entire quarterly reports, and you start
digging through and you discover that
the 10% jump came almost entirely from
sales made by the company in the last
two weeks of the quarter for which they
haven't been paid yet. It shows up in
your statement of cash flows as
receivables jumping.
Well, that's not a great price in a
earning speed. You might decide that
that's a lower quality positive surprise
than one where the company sold more
than expected and made more than
expected. So, the quality of earnings
matters, which also means that your
accounting has to get much more solid.
You agree? You have to play the role of
a forensic accountant and not just react
to the top line or the bottom line
number.
Second, and this is I think one way to
measure earnings quality is look at
accrual earnings, which is what
companies report as earnings per share.
But then if you look at the full state
financial statement, you look at the
statement of cash flows, you can look at
cash earnings. Companies where accrual
earnings jump a lot, but cash earnings
don't, you have to be a little more
skeptical than companies where both
increase. So, earnings quality matters,
and there are forensic accounting
metrics you can use to gauge the quality
of earnings.
As I mentioned earlier, companies
increasingly have come under pressure.
And many have done this voluntarily when
they report their earnings to also give
you give investors guidance about what
they see coming down the pipe in the
next year, the next 2 years in terms of
revenues and margins. So, a company
might say, "We beat earnings by 5% last
quarter, but you know what? Things don't
look great for the next year or the next
quarter, and we want to let you know."
We'll talk about why companies might
convey negative guidance or guidance
that doesn't look as upbeat as people
thought it was going to be.
But when that guidance comes out, just
as with the actual earnings, investors
are comparing the guidance to
expectations.
There have been times in the last few
years where companies beaten earnings
with its actual earnings, they have
beaten expectations, but provided
guidance that's so negative the stock
price drops.
And that guidance process troubles me a
little bit because it's open to gaming.
And here's what the gaming looks like.
Companies know that their earnings are
measured against expectations. One way
they can manage expectations is by
providing guidance that's more negative.
So, sometimes the negative guidance is
not so much because a company thinks the
future doesn't look as good, but because
they want to bring down expectations for
the next quarter so they can beat those
expectations.
You can already see that earnings report
day
is gaming personified in every dimension
because it's about managing and beating
expectations.
But if as an investor you decide that
you are going to build an investment
philosophy around earnings
announcements.
There are a couple of ways you can do
it, right? One is you can play the
drift. Take the companies with the most
positive earnings surprises with the
biggest jump on that that the day the
earnings come out and hold them hoping
and praying that the drift still
continues that company.
My guy my suggestion there is it's more
likely that you will see a drift in the
less followed smaller companies. So if
you're going to play this game, maybe on
those companies.
You know, smaller less liquid companies
because that's where the drift is going
to be greatest.
But the bigger money is actually getting
ahead of the game. One way you can get
ahead of the game is have access to
inside information about what's in the
earnings report, but that is potentially
illegal in much of the world.
Or you can do your own research and
perhaps you can come up with a better
way of forecasting what the earnings are
going to be than equity research
analysts are. And today we have the data
and the tools to be able to do this.
And maybe that'll become your
competitive advantage. It's a quarterly
earnings game and you're a little better
at it than the typical equity research
analyst and you use it to full effect
to capture that jump on in the price
around the most extreme announcements.
I hope you found the session useful.
And I thank you very much for listening.